this episode brought to you by
stamps.com why go to the store to get
stamps when you can have them printed
right at home for your convenience
[Music]
previously on exports 13 years ago hey
what's up I just saw x-men 3 yeah how
was it it was awful
really they focused a ton on Wolverine
yeah like everyone dies do they even
kill off Xavier oh my god this sounds
like the worst movie ever it is I'm
gonna hang up now because of how angry I
am as you should
good bye Billy hey what's up I just saw
Logan yeah how was it really they focus
a ton on Wolverine yeah like everyone
died dude oh my god this sounds like the
best movie ever it is I'm gonna hang up
now because of how happy I am as you
should
this was worth staying in the same spot
and never changing my clothes for a
decade
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome back to X month well now we look
at one of the most hated x-men movies if
not the most hated x-men movie x-men the
last and what the drinking sure now
being filled by Brett Ratner from one
not a controversial director to another
it's been the last damn wasn't less than
a critical darling and an absolutely
despised addition to the x-men franchise
fans hated how many characters died how
unfocused it was how it seemed to amount
to nothing how would kill President
Kennedy how it caused the Great
Depression and how it directed nor
mother nor to you couldn't contain the
amount of hatred this movie got and
still gets today I kind of have a soft
spot for okay I'm not insane I know this
movie is bad and doesn't work from a
structural standpoint it's one of the
worst sequels ever made especially when
you get to the end but after how boring
and Wow is the other two were out of the
original three I kind of consider this
one the most entertaining it has the
most wrists the most action the most
color the most mutants and the most
compelling ideas outside of just
torturing socks oh sure it's story and
characters are weak and the ending
doesn't really go anywhere but I'm
trying to use to that in these movies by
now I mean what's worse safe bland
middle-of-the-road tedium or batshit
insanity that never once left you bored
well that's the geeky complication we're
gonna analyze here today let's take a
look at the clearly bad my opinion
enjoyably bad x-men the last step the
film opens several years ago with a
mostly convincing age restoration of
Xavier played again by Patrick Stewart
magneto on the other hand played again
by Iain McKellen is looking more like a
ps4 character when are you gonna stop
lecturing me then you start listening
yeah because I need you oh yes the
pictures have told us they go to visit a
young Jean Grey who apparently has
unbelievable powers to make people look
less like their action figures
Jeanne's powers seem to be running amok
but xavier says he can help her control
it did you think you were the only one
of your kind yet and I hope never to
bring this up or think about it the
majority of times we meet Oh Jean by the
way to save all the mutants of the world
it'd be extremely helpful if you could
you know unleash that most powerful
entity in the universe thing nothing
nada got this better make more sense
when your sons are stuck meanwhile at a
later date gasp this a timeline or a
math problem we get a pretty grisly
scene of a young mutant trying to cut
his wings from his back this kid
deserves a freakin Oscar for the less
than one minute of acting that he's
given
Wow I can't wait to see the development
they give this character to justify such
horrific imagery how much screen time
does he have should i get used to things
being dramatically built up with no
payoff back in the not-too-distant
future x' Pass we see storm played again
by Halle Berry and Wolverine played
again by Hugh Jackman trainee young
mutants in a lawsuit battlefield the
whole world's gonna know you're just
gonna sit there come on it's the third
one we're all on autopilot here we
couldn't kill down here oh you read the
reviews Logan has non-russian Colossus
throw them at the threat and the sigh of
disappointment is given when you realize
the upside-down fakes Sentinel head is
far better looking than the actual
Sentinels we would get later class
dismissed
BB I love him they turn off the holodeck
I mean Danger Room and they're both
owned by the same guy as rogue Anna
Paquin is pissed at her boyfriend Iceman
is getting too friendly with another
mutant named Kitty Pryde played by Ellen
Page something's wrong what's wrong is I
can't touch my boyfriend without killing
him other than that I'm wonderful again
nailing her character great and I ever
flirt me for showing you you're a guy
Bobby reminds on me on one point I'm
gonna go talk to that gambit boy no wait
that's what the fans would want we don't
do that in these movies meanwhile
Cyclops james marsden is having trouble
coping with genes death from the last
movie I know how you feel don't when
gene died I said don't maybe it's time
for us to move on you and I that one
night of passion it's over now not
everybody heals as fast as you love it
well I am pretty awesome we then cut the
Beast
I mean Beast I mean kelsey grammer is
beast I mean Beast yeah they mail beef
it's amazing how well the gatha's
character down from his casting to his
makeup to his sophistication to his
animal-like fighting even him reading
upside down next to Wolverine and Xavier
this is as perfect a realization of a
cinematic x-man can be a major
pharmaceutical company has developed a
mutant antibody a way to suppress the
mutant x-gene permanently how am I
taking him so seriously when that
ridiculous amount of makeup is staring
back at me he looks like a Rogaine Smurf
and yet I'm hanging off of his every
word even the world they inhabit seems a
little bit more evolved as mutants are
now being hired into political office
and people
focus lesson wiping them out as much as
helping them out so even that's quite a
loaded issue as well apparently a quote
cure for mutation has been found
ironically in a mutant who can take
people's powers away if they come near
him they transform this into a drug that
can take mutant powers away and
unsurprisingly this causes a lot of
controversy I mean what kind of coward
would take it just to fit it is it
cowardice to save oneself from
persecution this is a callback to one of
the best x-men cartoons entitled the
cure we're mutants try to figure out
whether or not it's ethical to be free
of their powers give this movie credit
for asking similar difficult questions
is mutation something to be fixed like
bad vision or is it a part of your
identity and what makes you who you are
should you change or society change
mutants have different responses
depending on their powers not all of us
can fit in so easily you don't shit on
the furniture is it true they can cure
us they can give us real access there's
nothing to cure that's wrong with you or
any of us for that matter I do also give
credit that storm has a bit more
character in this than the previous
films though maybe it's just a better
wake their affliction is nothing more
than a disease and this site once the
world's most famous prison will now be
the source of freedom yes
I'm sure going to Alcatraz to have
people who see you as a disease
genetically alter you won't be
intimidating at all these so-called
mutants are people just like us
but I stand here today to tell you that
there's hope you know I want to listen
to this guy but I keep looking around
expecting to see one of the Penguins
goons to flip in and steal his baby
however some groups are taking this
further as magneto infiltrates an angry
gathering of mutants by the way doesn't
anyone clean up churches in the
not-too-distant future make no mistake
my brothers they will draw a first blood
any question is who will you stand with
the humans or us I'll be selling my CDs
in the back I live stream Thursdays
it's all pretty tough for a guy in a
cape you know you're talking to
do you the gritty reboot of Sonic the
Hedgehog meanwhile Cyclops returns to
her Jean was lost but discovers she's
not quite dead now you know every stone
dead in a moment there's sadly a lot of
truth to that she shows off to Cyclops
how powerful she's become by coming back
to life controlling his laser eyes and
as if that wasn't enough she blows him
up
oh no not Cyclops he was a character
anyway I've seen Westworld I know he'll
be right back get to alkali lake Xavier
feels a great disturbance in the x4 so
he sends storm and Logan to check it out
and they discover Jean is still alive
but how can that be well that much
built-up Phoenix saga is about to pay
off
involving aliens and Firebirds and
several levels of psychological and
physical identity powers wrapped her in
a cocoon of telekinetic energy ok Jean
develops a dual personality that in our
sessions came to call itself the Phoenix
what what there's a woman in front of us
the Jean Grey we know or the Phoenix
furiously struggling to be free so no
aliens no Firebirds only one personality
and all this is happening because of
water yeah they say Xavier kept it
dormant but they never said what
triggered it back to full four so the
only conclusion we can come to is water
just add water boom crazy boy The Wizard
of Oz would have been a different flake
if that was the outcome oh no you don't
you even wish don't be go
part of my yeah Dorothy what did you
think would happen well I thought she
would melt that is the stupidest thing
I've ever heard you say no I thought
that you know Oh mom's still here so the
first person to be given the cure is the
creator's son the boy we saw in the
opening named Archangel in that the
credits call on that but nobody in the
movie ever does I promise you
oh man I'm glad he didn't take it oh not
for any ethical reasons it's just the
wings of the only way I can tell him
apart from Malfoy and just to be overly
dramatic divorce her for practical
people
I'm here to shove a visual metaphor down
moviegoers throats
maybe then metaphor would have worked if
it wasn't used on characters who had
less than five minutes on screen both
the person being watched and the person
watching are barely in this weird hell
feeling for an image and relating to an
image seem to be intertwined now I'm
sure this will be underwhelming too as
magneto plans to break out mystique
who's been captured by law officials not
what isn't gonna use this deadly marbles
again maybe lift a car
well that was awesome oh I mean uh
nothing's good in this movie he puts her
out which I kind of enjoy seeing how she
broke him out in the previous film and
yeah well in this mutant criminal
grocery store he decides to go shopping
James madrix he was arrested for being
set to McFarlane five times when once
was already too many what did they call
you
juggernaut he was arrested for quoting
internet memes oh the juggle yeah yeah
we'll get to it one of the guards try
shooting the Cure at them as mystique
gets hid and transforms into a human
thus magneto abandons her presumably
because she lied about being a real
redhead now on the one hand I kind of
like this it emphasizes how deep his
prejudice goes and like no sack see
moron bigots he's consistent in how
hypocritical he is but there is one huge
problem with this the situation should
go more like oh dear well I better take
you to my machine that turns people into
mutants I know it had a few problems but
with me being a scientist and there
being great breakthroughs in DNA
transformation you can totally work with
this oh wait I guess that's off the
table now okay laters I mean the fact
that you grew up as a save your sister
was totally fine but yeah that still
doesn't connect to any of these beasts
is outraged that the Cure has been
weaponized without his knowledge thus he
tells the president he's resigning
someone fire or resigning from the
president's cabinet man that's rare
these days have you even begun to think
what a slippery slope you're on I have
and I worry about how democracy survives
when one man can move cities with his
mind that's do I you and I know that
it's only going to get worse all the
more reason why I need to be where I
belong
Wow both of them are asking very tough
polarizing questions kinda makes you
wonder what you would do if you were put
in a similar scenario no I mean it sucks
every part of this sucks it's
transformers twelve
meanwhile the supposed and most
dangerous mutant in the world wakes up
with just Wolverine as security you know
it's becoming easier and easier to
believe that the apocalypse happened
four
in these movies one of them is called
that and it appears she's not in control
that remarkable metal doesn't run
through your entire body does it but
Fifty Shades of Jean Grey will have to
wait as she busts out and goes to her
parents despite her parents never
showing up in the rest of the movie it's
not the first time in these films
someone abandons what's supposed to be
the most important what the hell are you
doing here visiting about a friend
magneto and his goons are there as well
that's Xavier in him agreed to approach
her alone I came to bring Jean home
don't interfere Attica
just like old times huh she needs help
okay this visual needs sitcom music
one's a peaceful professor the other a
genocidal extremist together they have
to convince a woman not to blow up the
world because everyone thinks the Dark
Phoenix is the only part of the Phoenix
there was can they stop her insanity
while having a little fun along the way
Fox presents jean-luc and Gandalf some
wacky wood from wacky Brits they do a
good job making Jean pretty intimidating
and downright creepy at times but we're
going back to her childhood home there's
no exploring her past her psychology
what led her to this mental state she
just starts tossing shit yeah that's not
like the Phoenix had any mental play
whatsoever that's it
even the fight despite it being
impressively choreographed doesn't make
a whole lot of sense magneto says nobody
can suicide well obviously the first
thing to do then is throw them inside so
let's be honest that was only done for
this stunt which makes no sense but I
still frigging love yes gene takes
house-flipping a little too seriously
Xavier gives Logan one final look before
being turned into powder deck slacks
that's the look of a guy saying you're
going to be changing me in the near
future so x-man Xavier is extinct as
magneto steals Jean away and the x-men
realized they have to carry on not only
without their leader Cyclops but without
their mentor Xavier as well gee I've
never seen that done in these movies
before we must carry on his vision Oh
world unite this hits our x-men pretty
hard especially on which one was Juno
again kitty oh yeah Kitty Pryde it has
been over 40 minutes since we've given
her or Iceman a scene so
yeah there's nothing to help get over
the death of your mentor like flirting
with someone you barely know why your
current girlfriend watches what Amex
hold where you going you don't know what
it's like to be afraid of your powers
hello I want to be able to touch people
Logan I hope you're not doing this for
some boy
no it's for some boy oh yeah that's
totally what I'm doing well if you want
to go then go just be sure it's what you
want well I don't know if it's what I
want I haven't asked Bobby yet
[Applause]
[Music]
to a snack uh Douglas don't you ever
knock Douglas were you looking at
stamps Douglas it's not what you think
Douglas I think it's time we had a talk
Douglas it's perfectly normal for a
human being to want to look at stamps
Douglas do you really mean it Douglas
the only problem is it's such a hassle
to go to the post office to pick them up
Douglas you shouldn't have to go to the
post office or just look at them online
you can print them out at home at
stamps.com Douglas Wow of course I'm
talking no one really is time to go to
the post office as Douglass's we're busy
that's why stamps.com is there as one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses Douglas you know when
you mail out merchandise you have to go
to the post office to get a stamp well
you don't have to with stamps com
Douglas that's amazing Douglas I like
pointing over that way for some reason
Wow stamps.com brings the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even
warehouse sending out thousands of
packages stamps com can handle it all
with ease Wow
Douglas stop saying that Wow that list I
take it back it's growing on me Wow
Douglas it's annoying me again but
stamps.com is and how Iowa simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send once your mail is ready just hand
it to your mail carrier or drop it in
the mailbox it's that simple
Wow plus I just haven't said Douglas for
a while so I'm saying Douglas Wow with
stamps come you give five cents off
every first class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps.com is a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already used stamps calm Wow
unless I actually have a special offer
for the people watching right now notice
that's right we're being watched it's
kind of creepy my viewers get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
this stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type
nostalgia that stamps comm enter
nostalgia Douglas you see stamps are a
wonderful thing especially with
stamps.com
there I go pointing that way again
Douglas thank you for being so
understanding about stamps it makes me
not feel so bad that I look up envelopes
hey Vance com why go to the store to get
stamps when you can have them printed
right at home for your convenience hey
everybody just letting you know we're
gonna be at c2e2 in Chicago
that's me Brad Jones Rob Malcolm Tamra
and a whole bunch of the channel awesome
gang are gonna be there we also have a
panel movies everybody disagrees with
you on where you get to talk about the
movie that everybody well disagrees with
you on it's your panel it's a lot of fun
we've got the booth that this kinda ton
of times it's a lot of fun and we'll see
you there
[Applause]
so remember how Jean even though she
wasn't really developed I mean okay
we're used to that in these movies but
she was at least a little creepy we'll
talk about the window as for the
majority of the rest of the movie she
does nothing but give one blank stare
again something we sadly become familiar
with in these films she made her choice
now it's time we make ours so if you're
with us then be with us again give
credit that at least storm has a bit
more character taking a little bit more
charge and this maybe kind of ties into
fans that believe she should have been
the leader of the x-men instead of
Cyclops but every time Jean is even
close to being more developed they
always push away in some cases literally
like when Wolverine tries to track her
down I came for key you think I'm
keeping her against her will
sorry we're paying her by the line in
this one you've just seen the deal we
got with Cyclops you don't know what
you're dealing with I know full well I'm
gonna make you do stupid things we're
getting yourself now go
[Music]
look out you'll run into ash from people
there too
[Music]
the SWAT team finds Magneto's army but
it turns out it was just multiple man as
a diversion okay I give up ah now I'm
gonna be sent back to jail and have my
powers taken away why did I agree to
this magneto is actually throwing a
mutant pride parade as he plans to get
his army to Alcatraz via the holy shit
amazing scene
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus Christ that's not x-men at all no
no no that's you never see that in a
comic and it's not imaginative not big
or epic or anything like that is it's
it's lazy it's it's it's stupid it's
incompetent it's God that still holds up
though it is funny how it goes from dusk
to complete night in a matter of a few
seconds and I do mean a few seconds
actually that reminds me
hey then we haven't seem to shoot at
dusk today yeah but since it starts at
5:00 and it's 5 o'clock right now but
that should give us plenty of time to
shoot no it's actually 501 now we just
missed it curses how did this happen I
don't know climate change how's that
affect the sunset I don't know she's
always climate change things are always
so strange we do too or around that's
weird
just things get a lot more normal when
you aren't around Magneto's army plans
to kill the boy supplying the cure but
they have a lot of obstacles to get
through in chess the pawns go first I
call them the test audience but the
x-men show up to stop them and the not
the least bit kickass climax begins
[Applause]
just trying to find something awesome in
this movie like juggernaut and kitty
pryde chasing each other to concrete
walls pedestrian setting projectile cars
on fire
boring kelsey grammer as beast watching
into the air roaring and ripping people
to shreds Oh have you even read an x-men
comic
where's Xavier showing a girl around
cerebro for hours that's the kind of
excitement that ignites the imagination
oh don't worry though there's still
plenty of stupid to go around like this
line that launched a million groans
don't you know who I am
I'm the geminal bitch yeah if you want
to know what every x-men fans reaction
was to this internet meme suddenly
making it into a big blockbuster movie
it went exactly like this don't you know
who I am I'm the geminal bitch and
there's this scene where the mutants
tried to kill the scientists in charge
you're the guy that invented the Cure
right yup that's her please don't do
this I don't want to help you people do
we look like we need your help all we
need is a script doctor
yeah thank you to headless screen time
than the catering credit got the same as
dad because that's what it's all about
Wolverine even Maja's to learn how to
work with the x-men as a team
best defense is a good offense because
that's what it's all about
also gotta love how beast resigns
because they weaponized secure and he
uses the weaponized cure to inject
magneto you and I know that it's only
going to get worse all the more reason
why I need to be where I belong in the
hypocritical gray zone jacuzzi that this
film is keeping me nice and warm in she
decides once again to go berserk though
as she begins wiping out everybody on
the island so far done is it does it
look like he's asking the audience that
upon finishing the film rock so if I'd
done
[Applause]
you ever wonder if this is Thanos is
porn like he just stays up late at night
like oh yeah turn them to dust you sexy
thing turn them to dust god I'm lonely
it looks like Wolverine is the only one
who can approach her do two is fast
healing I guess that kind of looks like
a Firebird even though you promised us
an actual Firebird but I guess they
meant a symbolic Firebird
[Music]
what I know you want to see me naked but
can I go one of these movies with my
body mostly covered I'm tired of people
seeing my Hugh Jackman he gets her back
to her normal self just so he can kill
her yep she came back and went crazy
just so she could die again yeah that's
actually all they do with her Matt
creates Jean man destroys Jean man
recreates Jean man destroys Jean man
this movie's bullshit and the ending
only gets worse from here we see Kitty
Pryde at Xavier grave because clearly no
other character had a stronger
connection with him as these movies have
now gone full force into making rogue
barely recognizable don't 100%
unrecognizable as she had her powers
taken away it's what I want
oh so she did it for herself
now let's reconnect with a boy who was
about to cheat on you because he
couldn't touch you and remind yourself
that had nothing to do with him cuz
that's what this is all about Hey look
Wolverine is proud that beast is back in
the white house putting their
two-sentence rivalry behind them way to
go furball because that's what this was
all about Logan tries to figure out if
he owns the school or what nothing else
is discovered about his past despite the
other films talking about it I mean
poorly but they did talk about it and we
see Magneto's powers are coming back
proving the Cure pointless
Xavier comes back to life proving his
death pointless but that arc angel kid
is still flying around in the background
for a millisecond thus that's what this
was all about I have no idea what this
movie was about for a film called the
last dance it doesn't stand by jack shit
this movie raises the stakes racist the
body count raises the issues and
questions and yet never follows all the
way through so it ends up saying nothing
want proof there's an alternate ending
where rogue doesn't get the cure
proving even they had no idea what they
were trying to say I couldn't do it I'm
sorry Bobby
this is me the whole movie just feels
like a lot of big scenes that never
connect or build up to anything and when
you have a movie that makes a lot of
huge choices resulting in a lot of huge
deaths it has to amount to something
you can't back down on that with that
said well I'm still a lot of amazing
scenes to appreciate some great action
great effects great makeup great ideas
and yes even some great character
moments all of these scenes on their own
would be fine maybe that's why a lot of
them have so many hits on YouTube
because individually they're really
impressive and deserve more credit when
people just scoff that there's nothing
good in this bill but it's the
equivalent of having all your favorite
food on one plate alone they're great
altogether
it's a giant mess so yes in comparison
to the other films that while slow and
uneventful did have a beginning middle
and end this tosses all of that away for
some big scenes that practically destroy
what the other films were trying to do
in that respect it's one of the worst
sequels ever made because it
disappointed fans who really got into
these movies but for me I never got that
much into these movies I thought they
were OK at best
I watched them because I liked x-men but
these films never really represented
x-men at least not the x-men I was
familiar with
they were dull colorless restrictive
middle-of-the-road adventures from a
franchise that was the exact opposite of
that this one at least was big loud fun
energetic imaginative visually stunning
action-packed and had good dilemmas
despite them never following all the way
through with it so while it is
technically bad when I think of the
bombastic cool adrenaline-filled x-men
fighting against varying types of
prejudice this is the one that gives me
a more enjoyable time so it's picking
your poison the safer blender but
ultimately better put together films or
the over-the-top hyper punch fest that
constantly insults your intelligence
whatever you choose one thing's for sure
for some this is an enjoyably bad movie
but it is still a bad
well that about does it for X month the
next week I have a brand new movie to
review whom aren't you forgetting
something
wow he has really repressed x-men
origins Wolverine hasn't he yeah that's
why I put a copy of it under his desk to
remind him he needs to review it
I'm the germinal bitch
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing
health write international this is a
global health and human rights
organization that was founded in 1990
their goal is to leverage global
resources to address local health
challenges and create sustainable
solutions they've worked in over 30
countries with current projects in Kenya
Mexico Nepal Russia the Ukraine the
United States and Vietnam so many people
all over the world have been helped by
this great organization and you can play
a big part in continuing that help click
on the link below and show your support
for the good things this charity does
for good people
[Music]
you